it's an unlikely battleground in the
fighting in ukraine the culture war just
before launching his invasion vladimir
putin dismissed ukraine's idea of
sovereignty he claimed the country was
created by russia and was a part of
russia
i will start by saying that modern
ukraine was entirely created by russia
by bolshevik communist russia to be
exact
this process began right after the 1917
revolution
but his comments have fueled an interest
in ukrainian history bookstores like
this one in central kiev are reporting
the shells where they keep the history
books are emptying fast i'm so
inspired because of this i'm happy
because
i can see how much our
society grows
every day and all these people like
little stars in a beautiful sky
i just can see all these
interested eyes and uh happy to help
them
we met vladimir vyatrovich at the golden
gate the ancient entry point to the city
of kiev a historian and politician he
says putin's claims are nonsense
absolutely ukraine has a deep history
like many other european countries we
take our roots from medieval times in
the 9th century when the state was
created the center of the state was
where we are standing now
the bookstore is currently collecting
russian books people turn them in and at
the end of august they will be sent to
be pulped
any money raised will go to help the war
effort
this woman brought in 47 books
not only do i not want to read russian
books i want nothing more to do with
russians we have great ukrainian writers
and beautiful great ukrainian literature
but it's all sold out at the moment
there is an ideological question on one
side it's sad to let go of these books
but this will also benefit our common
victory
vladimir putin insists that russia and
ukraine are essentially one nation that
is not a view that is popular here
people believe the country is in a war
not just for territory but for a
separate cultural identity
and many people are now finding that as
a part of that there is a history to be
rediscovered
and celebrated
alan fisher al jazeera keeve